[Music]
the reality is in you know be very since
I'm among friends here I'll be very
honest um yeah I eat one meal a day and
that's just because I do feel sluggish
bite more net now that meal is a
prodigious proportion it's uh I describe
it as anything I can reach until I fall
asleep so you know it's just habit I got
in many many years ago and so it's just
one of those things in terms of the
amount of sleep I slept about that
because that's how much time I had if I
had more time I'd be happy to sleep more
and I you know I certainly when I get
the chance to do but I did find out that
that's about the balance that I needed
to at that point to do the things I did
and so what I tried to do was hit a
balance that made me feel right I got up
early in the morning and worked out
because that was important for me to get
the day going then I had some quiet time
alone to work then I did most of the day
at visit troops and all and then in the
evenings I start to fade in in energy
and so what I learned to do was put
those things that don't require
analytical thought later in the day I
mean guys would learn not my staff would
learn not to come to me for really good
decisions at night but I could sign
stuff I mean I could do you know those
kinds of things yeah I mean you got to
know your limitations but I also learned
to have people around me that really
understood I was very transparent about
my battle rhythm um strengths and
weaknesses that could fill in the gaps
but could also know when I'm best in the
day how much sleep I need I had a
certain you know guy worked with it just
was very protective of that at times
he'd say stop it go to bed you know that
sort of thing is important I think all
those things are really important on a
couple levels one when you're in an
organization people want to know that
you are somebody that they have respect
for I think if your life is if your
health is in a shambles if your finances
are in a shambles if your personal life
center shambles you're not going to
build as much confidence in them as if
you got your act together so it's just
like if they see you cheat
their tax on your taxes and they wonder
how you're going to deal with them in a
business sense they're going to do the
come you know the calculation if he lies
to the US government you might lie to me
too
all those things matter and I think you
don't need to make a big publicity about
it people will watch you enough to know
whether you're you've kept up but it's
not something just for you you owe it to
them gotta be centralized organization
yeah yeah change up my system change the
world
[Music]